bonjour de rio de janeiro 10 venu à
l'épicerie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
cette semaine nous sommes briser la
région plus précisément où se tiendront
comme vous le savez les jeux olympiques
mais pétrie vous prépare des reportages
sur les émissions et les produits
brésiliens certains entre autres on
trouve même chez nous sur les tablettes
de positif dans les prochaines émissions
il sera question du plan national du
brésil la tête giada de leurs nouveaux
leviers de l'alimentaire mais tout
d'abord on vous parle d'un produit qui
est un symbole au même titre que la
samba et le football le café petit matin
d'automne la rio de janeiro les cadeaux
offerts sont à la plage sur les
terrasses
on savoure la boisson du pays le café
[Musique]
que vous voyons probablement ici
construits avec l'argent du café c'est
le café qui a façonné le pays
le brésil est le plus grand exportateur
au monde
nathan être vite et le directeur de
l'association brésilienne de l'industrie
du café
il représente 80 % des producteurs
wazemmes
mignonne des pauvres voire brésiliens
travaillent dans l'industrie du café
avec 40% de parts de marché le café du
brésil se consomme partout sur la
planète et pourtant on ne voit pas sur
les étalages de nos épiceries pour
canada en épicerie dans les restaurants
on voit beaucoup de café du costa rica
du kenya on envoie du terreau jamais ou
rarement du brésil
photo cl 1 c'est à dire au monde qu'un
café brésilien de qualité existent il
est disponible
c'est un problème de marketing que nous
nous efforçons de résoudre en vérité on
retrouve les cafés brésilien dans notre
quotidien mais ils se cachent dans des
mélanges vendus sous diverses marques
starbucks du molleton l'arabe ni café
nespresso
pendant des années on a privilégié la
quantité plutôt que la qualité mais les
choses sont en train de changer
à l'invitation de nathan nous nous
rendons nous accompagner dans notre
guide pedro dans une plantation à sept
heures de route à l'ouest de rio une
boîte
il y a dans l'état de sao paulo des
milliers de plantation de café touba
espirito santo pignal ici l'effet est au
centre de la vie les gens à la
coopérative on a même et rigide chapelle
en l'honneur de nossa senhora do café
leur patronne
selon lui 150 non pas selon nous au rial
[Musique]
henrique et anna gallucci sans
propriétaire d'une plantation de café
[Musique]
nous arrivons en pleine face
les cerises de café sans écossais à la
main ou à la machine
[Musique]
elles sont ensuite l'avé trier ou séchés
à l'air libre
[Musique]
sur une plantation de café 75 cofonda
récolte donne un grain de qualité
intermédiaire
seuls 25% et en chercher d'autres
une enveloppe rouge j'ai mon grain de
café qui est pas maturité mais c'est le
grain de café qu'on va terrifier
éventuellement leur idole une fois le
taux d'humidité de 12% atteints on
décortique les cerises pour en extraire
deux grains verts appelé les grands crus
et moi c'est beau café là est ce que je
peut le boire au canada et ce cas
facebook a fêté à la conso mire du nord
canada
tous les médias expliquaient que nous
vivons le cas s'est immédiatement au
canada par contre les canadiens sont un
petit peu fermé pour le marché brésilien
d'accord à cause de sa réputation avant
d'avant la perception qu'on entend c'est
qu'elle a cassé brésilien c'est un café
une offre qui goûte rien qu'on mêle aux
autres cafés pour avoir du goût mais ô
combien taille des pierres visant le
capi brésilien avait mauvaise réputation
depuis les années 90 on a fait des
efforts pour améliorer la qualité et les
gens qui l'achètent le savent
cette réputation et harcèlent les
producteurs en sont conscients et ils se
sont donné les moyens pour confectionner
avec les grands classiques du monde
à la coopérative
chaque producteur fait analysé son café
pour définir la classification du grain
et son taux d'humidité
[Musique]
on dort ici une petite 106 et en évaluer
le goût et les arômes et le degré
d'acidité
ces étapes sont sociales pour déterminer
le niveau qualité du café et son free
chercher ses efforts pour encadrer la
qualité des effets commencent à porter
nous essayons de travailler en symbiose
avec les producteurs et nous avons
trouvé d'excellents café au brésil
isabelle a rapporté race et barista et
propriétaire du célèbre car si lad de
sao paulo
reconnu mondialement elle cherche à
faire connaître et les meilleures
récoltes de son pays au fil des sons été
payée a retracé à ce fléau à l'origine
nokia s'est comblé des mélanges nos
meilleurs grains étaient mélangés parmi
d'autres et on ne pouvait les déceler
maintenant nous multiplions les
dégustations
nous sommes à la recherche de grands
crus et nous voulons les faire connaître
et ne croyez noir nous avons maintenant
des cafés complexe les cafés unique peut
être pas disponible partout mais nous
les avons
et les gens surtout en europe commencent
à découvrir que nos cafés peuvent être
d'origine unique
à présent nous pouvons nous mesurer au
café africain ou d'amérique centrale
li brésilien humaine ou comment être
fiers de la qualité de leur verser les
étalages d efficy de sao paulo regorge
de ces produits des cafés d'origine
qu'on aimerait bien retrouver chez nous
alors siens au canada on va voir qui a
fait du brésil et espère au canada sera
reconnaître bientôt la valeur du caté
brésilienne
l'initiative est lancée en ce sens et je
pense qu'elle portera ses fruits dans
votre pays du bois rouge au son du
frappeur de vue à pois youtube juillet
[Musique]
non
voici le marché et faire un livre est en
plein coeur de rio un marché qui fait
comme on en retrouve tous les jours dit
alex l'un au retour de la pause en se
transporte à l'heure de l'apéro pour du
vin ils viennent au frais
[Musique]
on
mais on nous propose plusieurs façons de
garder le vin biais nos frais l'épicerie
a fait pour vous les sacs isothermes
[Musique]
l'été la chaleur un don vin blanc ou
rosé qu'on déguste également bien frais
mais pas d'eau pas notre innocence à 2,3
degrés donc laisser ça à moi parce que
c'est ensemble comme ça ça peut
réchauffer assez vite
elle ne veut pas que ce soit trop non
plus l'alcool vous mettrez l'autre est
présent on va pas percevoir la 6 et non
plus 10 20 on essaie toujours de garder
cette fraîcheur mais si on a oublié de
placer sa bouteille au frigo au moins
deux heures et demie au préalable ou une
cinquantaine de minutes au congélateur
on peut la plongée 18 minutes dans un
seau avec de la glace et de l'ue pas
d'eau pas de glace qu'à cela ne tienne
sur le marché on retrouve plusieurs
enveloppes qui prétendent à baisser
rapidement la température de notre
précieux nectar on a six buts et
température pièce we chacune des
enveloppes parfait la plupart prétend
pouvoir refroidir le vin elle aurait
rien qu'une façon de savoir c'est de le
tester ce que nous allons faire crier on
l'est on va mettre des enveloppes
selon le mode d'emploi
les enveloppes dont les prix varient de
4 1 34 dollar ont été mise au
congélateur pendant au moins 6 heures
on parle les chronos ne brille elle
s'essaie désormais ne demande que
quelques minutes pour votre chat noir
il parle de refroidissez vos bouteilles
à 5 minutes la chaîne longue garçon
celui là ici aussi on parle de en dire
en cinq minutes le trudeau aussi parle
de 5000 dalphond la c5 les deux minutes
ou quelques minutes reprend doucement
rapide
là ça fait quoi là ça fait presque
quatre minutes on a commencé on écrit on
a perdu deux de gruau depuis le début
est posté froid nous sommes bien loin de
la température idéale de 8 à 10 degrés
na 3 secondes
la démonstration est faite à 1 5 minutes
les appareils ne refroidissent peau
neuve et suffisamment pour se soigner
on va attendre un petit peu il y cinq
centres ont porté attendons dix minutes
certains cas déjà plus que 10 minutes
attendons quinze minutes attend donc une
demi heure
[Musique]
la démonstration est faite cela ne
fonctionne pas nous sommes au mieux à 17
degrés soit deux fois trop chaud pour
être bu et vérifications faites même
après une heure la température ne baisse
pas plus pour garder au frais je pense
que ça va être assez d'avoir une
enveloppe ça va chez des amis les termes
si on sort sur la barre d'action qu'on
veut pas sentir le seau à glace et l'eau
donc on se met ça c'est qu'on garde une
fin au frais
nous avons vérifié combien de temps les
bouteilles déjà froide rester fraîche
dans les enveloppes au début du tête la
température du vin était à 9 degrés dans
nos six bouteilles témoins résultat
toutes les enveloppes conserve bien le
vin aux frais la première demi-heure les
plus performantes étaient les deux
achetés chez renaud bray après deux
heures le vin est toujours à la bonne
température
conclusion les sacs réfrigérant
n'abaissons jamais les bouteilles de vin
à une température idéale pour la
dégustation
mais ils sont très utiles pour garder au
frais celle déjà froide resservir un
petit verre de vin c'est un des grands
plaisirs de l'été carmen helmand encore
faut-il leur servir la bonne température
ici au brésil on voit pas beaucoup de
buts que l'on consomme par contre à tout
moment de la journée c'est un instinct
c'est tout simplement les vais essayer
qu'on a broyé concert d'anvers volcom
ceci commence soit version sucrée avec
des granollers ou encore version
installée avec du tapioca les forces et
sont convaincus de son pouvoir
énergisante rester là après la pause le
barbecue nestlé fois aux accents boréale
ne passez pas par là
halak a l'air va la pente à la star
[Musique]
tous les produits qu'on utilise pousse
sur le sol et sur le territoire
québécois
aujourd'hui arnaud marchand cuisine
champignons grave sirop de bouleau et
livèche au menu un burger aux bisons et
légumes grillés pour la grillade de
légumes à prendre les courgettes les
asperges avec les panais on va juste les
enrobés avec un peu d'huile de canola
biologique
c'est très savoureux donc on se fait
surprendre il faut pas trop en mettre
parce que sinon ça va ça domine vraiment
dans la m
le fait de refermer le couvercle par
dessus ça va garder l'humidité du légume
très vite et qu'il décèle trop aussi
dans le barbecue
on va fermer en interne on va préparer
nos champignons je choisis donc les
champignons crabe à la base d'idées
blanc qu'il y ait bien orange parce que
si un autre champignon qui le mange
puissance partir de ce moment là qu'ils
développent plus la saveur qui ont dit
un côté plus une saveur maritime un
petit peu plus tard il fonctionne très
bien dans les tous qui à oman choses
comme ça donc on va l'utiliser en
produits séchés qui se trouve très
facilement
pour ce faire on leur hydrate qui on le
fait revenir dans un peu d'huile avec de
l'échalote française pour lui donner une
texture s'intéressant au tour d'un petit
peu aussi mes légumes grillés se sent
vraiment bon lundi très belles odeurs
qui se dégagent qu'il faut essayer de
faire avec ces produits là c'est des
produits quand même être d'excellente
qualité
c'est pas de les cacher
donc là je champignons sont prêts on la
grillade de légumes dans les sens les
recoupe qui on va pouvoir ensuite
assaisonner avec du sirop de bouleau est
un petit peu de racines de ce match le
sirop de bouleau c'est vraiment le même
principe que le sirop d'érable
c'est la sève de l'arbre qui est
recueilli et ensuite qui réduit pour
avoir une consistance sirupeuse que
c'est ça qui se trame particularité on
est sur blue j'aime beaucoup le travail
est donc dans mes plats salés
donc ça c'est quelque chose qu'ils aient
qui se démarquent ça ramène un petit peu
amène encore du corps qui touche
d'amertume touche amertume et complexes
bouquet qui est vraiment agréable
ces messieurs c'est vrai que c'est à
mi-chemin entre sur des rabais la
mairesse dans un petit peu dessus et
pour finir un petit ingrédient que moi
je suis tombé en amour en fait avec ce
produit là c'est la racine de céleri
sauvage qui n'est autre que la racine de
l'hiver dans qui est déshydratée et puis
on peut là tout simplement la râpée donc
ça c'est très très très savoureux on va
on retrouve encore notre côté sellerie
qui je trouve ça vraiment intéressant
bien que la de l'odeur qui se dégage
ouais ça mériterait plus simple tout
autre mélange de petits légumes cuisinés
près la racine de ce riz sauvage c'est
la racine de l'hiver tout simplement à
l'état sauvage qui est ramassé qui est
séchée puis ensuite qu'ils ont comparé
rapper sur les plantes
ça va très bien avec les viandes
braisées par exemple
pour une variante visant j'ai voulu
vraiment laissé nature justement pour
qu'on puisse distinguer la saveur du
bison qui permet mas qui très savoureux
en viande hachée ça c'est vraiment mon
petit coup de coeur à chaque fois dans
mes bagages mais toujours un petit peu
de compotée d'oignons sur la viande on
ajoute ensuite du fromage dans ce cas ci
les reculs de charlebois et pour
terminer donc un petit grain de moutarde
qui vont comme amener un côté croquante
et un côté un petit peu épicée à la
recette
[Musique]
évidemment on a monté notre humble mais
on a mis nos yeux mais il nous manque là
pour faire la police ont fait blanchir
la livèche on ajoute un mélange de sucre
et du [ __ ] de sud est de la ville est
donc à l'image pour que le travail est
accrue donc les feuilles aimant ch et
pire un petit peu comme du persil qu'on
pourrait utiliser du persil met vraiment
en moins grande quantité parce que c'est
beaucoup plus prononçant sada c'est
utile dans la religion
un condiment donc on assaisonne un petit
peu comme on veut notre burger avait
peut-être réussi moi j'aime ça j'aime
ton qu'on goûte le bison chaque chose
est respectée en fait on a un petit peu
la graine de moutarde le fromage puis on
arrive temps en temps sur un petit
morceau de riches donc c'est cet
équilibre là que j'aime en fait d'un
homme dans un but comme ça
la brèche c'est quand même c'est pas ça
m'agace pas
lors d'un goûter aux légumes au 6 mai or
selon et tout ça c'est vraiment simple
j'ai des légumes grillés mais bien un
ciseau nos relations nous vous invitons
à nous faire part de vos questions
suggestions et commentaires par courriel
épicerie à roda radio canada.ca et vous
pouvez voir tous nos reportages sur
notre site internet
ici point radio syrie canada.ca barbe
les épiceries notre produit vedette
cette semaine c'est un aliment très
consommé ici au brésil il s'agit du
maniaque dans les marchés comme ici on
l'achète très entier ou encore on va les
plus est vous le coupez et vous le
présenter dans un sac dans l'eau pour
empêcher le sida sion après à la maison
souvent du brésilien va le manger un peu
comme la pomme de terre c'est-à-dire
doit partir ou encore le réduire en
purée
mais on aime particulièrement celle de
sardy fécule avec le manioc et on vante
à une crêpe très populaire dans les
restaurants dans la réunion à paris dans
les marchés on va aussi par une farine
avec le magna on va griller et qu'on va
servir avec les stars dans un marché
près de rio pour cinq reais autour de 2
$ vous allez avoir une loi sauf frêche
ici en vous la coop vous buvez
directement locaux faux sites très
populaires autant à la plage au marché
qu'à la maison
aussi pour de dollars vous pouvez avoir
des belles sardines fraîches
complètement après tu es toujours de
dollars un bon bol de presse une vie
brisée liés à cette surtout respect
sécher va coûter beaucoup moins cher et
ce jour au même prix vous avez une
douzaine de belles d'orange dû briser et
finalement toujours pour 5 créach vous
avez si louvel banane du pays
ces prix nous semble raisonnable c'est
quand même assez charge pour les
brésiliens qui gagnent en moyenne 1000 $
par année comparativement au salaire
annuel au canada qui étaient cinquante
mille dollars
enfin
aux enfants
notre prochain rendez-vous le nouveau
guide alimentaire brésilien en voie de
devenir un modèle et pourquoi d'après
vous partout fonctionner ses débuts la
fca qui rend ce guide extraordinaire
c'est qu'il nous invite à manger des
aliments et non de nutriments devraient
pas regarder de la nourriture et bourse
a cédé protéines et ça c'est des
glucides
il faut simplement savoir si ce sont de
véritables venu ici les charcuteries de
poissons et la grande popularité des
tortillas moi ça fait quinze ans que
j'avais deux sites sur début on allait
aux marchés latino qui avait 12 3
variétés
aujourd'hui on trouve jean comme 50
variétés de maïs qui sont faites aux
stationnés au mexique ici c'est vraiment
aujourd'hui a dit ousmane a
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh